Alan Vega ne penses-tu pas que tu es
le dernier travailleur sur terre sais pourquoi mais
les autres
qui descendent tu sais après moi seront
toujours c'est de cela qu'il s'agit n'est-ce pas
nous dire où il travaille je
n'en ai aucune idée
oui je  Je suis sûr que vous n'avez aucune idée d'où
venez-vous de New York
que faisiez-vous à New York avant
de faire Rock n Roll Oh
grandir grandir rester en vie comment avez-vous
rencontré Martin par accident je suis
entré dans la rue  comme ça, il est
juste ici
ouais regarde toujours dans le miroir ne penses-tu pas
que bébé jukebox restera dans le
Temple de la renommée du rock and roll pour toujours
oui pourquoi parce que c'est bon juste bon juste
bon ouais
madame.  bon comme tout le reste c'est leur
droit beaucoup de gens ont été inspirés par
toi maintenant mm-hmm
tu vends beaucoup ils ont volé du
travail ouais ouais de toi je suppose si
bien c'est tellement bon tu sais qu'ils ont volé
à la bonne personne ce bon goût
qui t'a dit tout le monde pas tout le monde je
ne veux pas descendre la liste est à peu près
aussi longue dans un camion nommé maintenant quoi de
lit tu sais tu connais tous les noms je
dois te dire que tu es un bon garçon tu
veux dire oui un  ange ces gars je pense
pourquoi un centime de suicide s'est séparé nous ne nous sommes jamais
séparés nous avons juste pris un petit pari tu as dit que
tu t'ennuyais avec Martin utilisant de la
synthase tout le temps et je n'ai jamais dit
qu'il est allé le sien tu sais qu'il est né
avec moi aussi ça va
légère question de guitares et
synthétisées c'est juste question d'une
musique différente tu sais tu vois
ce que je veux dire tu es une légende vivante du
monde du travail mais très peu de gens
écoutent ta musique comment tu en ressens je
ne sais pas c'est là c'est  il n'y a pas de
chance tu sais que c'est leur p  les problèmes ne sont pas les
miens
n'écoute pas un jour tu penses que le
vrai RocknRolla devrait être un perdant non le
gagnant ou un perdant je veux dire quelle est l'idée
du perdant le toxicomane
pense que le voyage est si dur
que tu sais que tu finiras par boire et te
droguer et tout juste pour essayer de
rester en vie dans un sens et sembler être en
très bonne santé Je suis ma propre cabine ouais
j'ai commencé à manger tu sais je '  j'ai
appris à manger en France tu connais le biome
mm-hmm et la libération ouais beaucoup je
te soutiens beaucoup oui que penses-tu
d'eux je les aime mec tu sais je
pense qu'acheter possède le meilleur cuisinier du
monde vraiment il est  le grand Liberace possède du
grand journal vous avez des pages entières à
chaque fois à Liberace sur mm-hmm
eh bien je le mérite vous le méritez pas
vraiment je plaisante mais baiioons
gris ne pensez-vous pas que c'est terrible de
se sentir comme un bon authentique  artiste et
être obligé de voyager en van d'un
club à l'autre parfois ici  parfois
ça devient dur mais d'autres fois j'y
pense parfois tu sais
parfois je suis très excité à ce sujet ça
dépend de ma vie à
ce moment là tu sais en ce moment c'est
agréable c'est comme si je serais à Paris
pendant 10 jours c'est super  c'est le bon
côté tu sais alors il y a le mauvais côté
donc c'est comme dans la vie tout n'est pas une
chose tu sais c'est l'une des autres tu
sais peut-être que tu devrais avoir une fille
tu ne penses pas non pas du tout - derrière
le temps  en fait personne ne pourrait être dans
le futur juste le reste du monde
vit dans le passé c'est tout ce que
tu penses que j'ai pensé travailler aujourd'hui c'est
assez terrible tu ne penses pas que je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait de rock and roll en
fait  plus tu sais mais ça
change ça s'est transformé en rap en d'
autres choses tu sais qui est le rock and
roll le rock and roll est le langage des
gens pour qui je veux avoir quelque chose de
fort à dire sur la vie ou quelque chose alors
tu sais que c'est un mot drôle rock et  rouler
mais c'est rock and r  oll signifie que si
Beethoven était rock and roll et qu'il est
temps que tu ne puisses pas entendre tu sais
qu'il joue très fort tu sais jouer à
playground 10 sur 10 tu sais comme ces
groupes ouvrent dix pourquoi tu aimes tellement Paris
oh c'est une ville très cool  c'est une
super ville c'est beau visuellement sa
nourriture est super les femmes sont super
il y a un son dans la ville parce que les
gens s'extasient sur vous entendez non non
j'étais amoureux de Paris avant de
sauver Paris avant d'être Alan Vega
je veux dire j'étais  venir toujours l'aimer
juste j'aime la culture tu sais Paris
n'encourageons pas beaucoup la France les
écrivains comme le Cameroun l'ont vu et tu
sais tout ça les peintres j'ai
toujours j'ai toujours aimé ça depuis que
je suis petit j'étais comme
Culture française je ne sais pas pourquoi ne me demandez pas
vous savez que mes parents ne sont pas français ou
quoi que ce soit mais alors quand je suis venu à Paris la
première place est venue dans son Paris quand
je suis venu d'Amérique j'ai toujours aimé
ça c'est tout je sais  tu regardes parfois le
plus grand  étoile ouais ouais bien sûr combien de
fois pas trop souvent tu ne le vois
plus ça fait trop longtemps l'
air est tellement pollué maintenant on ne peut plus le voir
mais quand tu vois quoi penses-tu que c'est
une belle tempête cet air probablement  vous
savez qu'ils ont découvert des planètes autour de l'
étoile il y a probablement une vie humaine mais
il y avait une sorte de vie
autour de cette étoile vous pensez que vous
irez là-bas un jour je pourrais venir de
là qui sait ah vous savez